gemeinsam anpacken vor dem axel springer
hochhaus in berlin bild leser und
firmenspenden am mittwoch kräftig für
die ukraine nacheinander waren mehrere
sattelschlepper auf den vorplatz der
axel springer se einmalhandschuhe
verbandszeug babynahrung konserven und
power bands werden verladen hunde und
katzenfutter windeln und zahnpasta land
ein lkw
erste lade bilanz fast 400 volle
umzugskartons plus 3.000 powerbags bild
dankt aldi nord fressnapf und procter
and gamble für die großzügige
unterstützung
am donnerstag wird der bild richter
ukraine fahren in begleitung eines
blicks busses für ein bild